it descends normally between around 5:00
and 7:30 p.m. and maybe at its height
around 6:00 especially when the weather
is turning and the last of the daylight
has burnished the sky a shade of crimson
pink the Sunday evening feeling is
ordinarily associated with work and the
idea of going back to an office after a
pleasant break but this doesn't quite
cover the complexity of what's going on
it isn't just that we have some sort of
work to do that's dragging down our mood
but rather that we're going back to the
wrong sort of work even while we are in
dire ignorant of what the right sort of
work might actually be we all have
inside us what we might term a true
working self a set of inclinations and
capacities that long to exert themselves
on the raw material of reality we want
to turn the vital bits of who we are
into jobs and ensure that we can see
ourselves reflected in the services and
products we are involved in turning out
this is what we understand by the right
job and the need for one is as
fundamental and as strong in us as the
need to love we can be as broken by a
failure to find our professional destiny
as to identify an intimate companion
feeling that we are in the wrong job and
that our true vocation lies undiscovered
is not a minor species of discomfort it
will be the central existential crisis
of our lives we normally manage to keep
the insistent calls of the true working
self at bay during the working week
we're so busy and so driven by an
immediate need for money but it reliably
comes to trouble us on Sunday evenings
like a ghost suspended between two
worlds it has not been allowed to live
or to die and so it bangs at the door of
consciousness requiring resolution we
are sad or panicked because a part of us
recognizes that time is running out and
that we are not presently doing what we
should with what remains of our lives
the anguish of Sunday evening is our
conscience
trying to stir us in articulately into
making more of ourselves in this sense
Sunday evenings have a history until
recently the last hundred years or so
there was for most of us no question of
our true working selves ever finding
expression in our Labour's we worked to
survive and would be grateful for a
minimal income but such reduced
expectations no longer hold we know
because there are enough visible
examples of people who've done so that
we could harness our talents to the
engines of business we know that we
don't have to be unhappy in the working
area which adds are feeling a particular
shame if we still are we shouldn't be so
hard on ourselves we don't yet have the
mechanisms in place to reunite ourselves
with our purpose it's in the nature of
our working selves to be both clear in
their dissatisfactions and yet
maddeningly oblique about their real
direction we can both be utterly sure
that we're not doing what we should
while wholly at sea about our genuine
purpose
the answer is patience structure and
steadfast intent we need some of the
discipline of the detective or an
archaeologist reassembling the pieces of
a smashed jar we shouldn't dismiss our
angst blithely just as the Sunday blues
to be a swage dwith a drink in a film we
should see it as belonging to a confused
yet utterly central search for a real
self that's been buried under a need to
please others and take care of
short-term needs for status and money in
other words we shouldn't keep our Sunday
evening feelings simply for Sunday
evenings we should place these feelings
at the center of our lives and let them
be the catalysts for a sustained
exploration that continues throughout
the week over months and probably years
and that generates conversations with
ourselves with friends mentors and
professionals something very serious is
going on when sadness and anxiety
descend for a few hours on Sunday
evenings we aren't a bit bothered to
have to end two days of leisure we're
being driven usefully to
distraction by a reminder to try to
discover who we really are and to do
justice to our true talents before it's
too late we publish new
thought-provoking films every week be
sure to subscribe to our Channel and
take a look at more of what we have to
offer at the link on your screen now
you